[Music]
for a tireless work in the Panama papers
and other leaks then I think this brave
works is really the essence of
journalism
we're witness I think you can see that
to obscure world tanks even industry is
massive the lack of transparency is
outrageous it's a dark side of the
mega-rich it's used for terror finance
organized crime corruption tax dodging
and so on and we see a lot of names that
we recognize Putin assets regime FIFA
officials the Icelandic Prime Minister
for mass planting prime minister what we
have found is clearly that the mega-rich
and the biggest corporations in this
planet they can you know become tax free
and law free it's systemic it's all over
the society is kondal is it the console
to please the battery 14a q-oco a
security or vaca need to improve safety
to pay a law which the banner points
from Posada - we have heard journalists
we have heard it's Birds there's no
political accountability in journalists
or experts but there is political
accountability in the Commission and
there is political accountability within
this house we get to deliver so
situation eval created in 2009 the two
foundations but now you're saying that
now you have no connection to them
xalapa suspicions a hundred it is a it
is a clay and only on Luke akka blue
bead official
CNRS immoral senator Multimedia's
contour alerts ability from cannot
preloaded the Fertile airport for an
intra santa pola live as of fiscal
optimization fiscal of code fiscal say
the mortal Jewry Dick Tracy laboulaye
said to sample more historical can hear
each take a steam kill Pedro deportiva
be mine Apple II Labs Oracle Karen valid
a transfer here to sana sana Sinatra be
it's almost even agree
especially Skoda Kosciusko LaVon affair
total montage ona intra-city
econ total more secretin sep exceeded
appearance epic amiodarone place a
necessity Mon sacrum psychic reproduce
on Melissa take home the sum total more
a pack a once a had evaded to
alternapalooza Sahara Nepal's si a final
sale libyan public Donna Lucia Lydia
Cacho LaHood Lisa hopper regard Sita it
would alter his cane activity
su say sube arabic Toyin missing allah
salla
china Kansas teaser felishj don't ask a
man ball and scene we see kleptocrats
from Angola or Azerbaijan or Russia
still the money and then try to launder
it transferring it into a European bank
and then invested for instance in
property or in legal corporations in the
European Union it's the same system that
is used by the way by the Mafia and all
sorts of criminal organizations we can't
accept that we don't know who owns the
company
the pollen transparents UCSD medicine
from their homeland in various lands
Anthony man or the Aegean Sea person I'm
built for shipment the sanctions are
very low so what we call for is high
penalties because then the financial
sector will also become more aware of
the cost of not having systems to
prevent money laundering we need to
reinforce the instruments of the law
enforcement and the tax authorities to
really go after the criminals we have to
make our own EU list of high-risk
countries for money laundering click on
CLE coolican city school is a vocally
bunkie you do have already caught a lot
mr. Shah physicality these are
professions that are supposedly
under self regulation one thing we have
encouraged that self regulation doesn't
work we need proper supervision
[Music]
the omission of Enid arpeggio on for
Angela icon house to Karen innocent
thought movie enhance and London Phelan
piccolo and Harvey these are often
unsurpassed we have called for a genuine
reform of the of the the secret working
groups in the council they have for
example the code of conduct group for
business taxation for now 20 years and
they're the country's sit behind closed
doors it's the game that all these
crooks are playing and they are not just
in the industries they have captured
people in our governments in other
administration's in our political
establishments to produce the laws or
not to produce the laws that would
indeed be enforced to regulate all this
some crucial elements of disclosure of
transparency are not acceptable by some
member states and who are these member
states exactly the ones who have
developed these industries of opacity
[Music]
I think is unacceptable that Credit
Suisse and UPS refuse to stand before
our committee and not only it's a
provocation for European Parliament but
I think more importantly to democracy
and the European citizens we need to end
the world of the mega rich and the big
corporations they are above the law
while the rest of the society has to
follow the law this is a fundamental
democratic problem was not religious and
offside VMO occasion Parliament
machination field for and via subsidy
McCartin above you often hear class et
the stimulus for cassia and we hope that
in the future a permanent inquiry
committee will be set up in this
Parliament so that member states as well
as all this cropped industry understands
that we're gonna go after them
you